welcome back to las vegas now it's
salute to superheroes thursdays and if
you missed it last week that is with the
help of
southwest medical and optimum care this
is our chance to honor our local and
everyday heroes in healthcare so let's
welcome this week's honorees dr ian chay
and maria sergio welcome
can you guys hear me yes we can hear you
oh good good good okay so first just
tell me how you guys feel
humbled and excited so i i am very
appreciative of this recognition so
thank you very much
absolutely and let's start by just
introducing your medical specialty let's
start with you maria
so my name is marie sergil i'm the nurse
manager for
our primary care adult medicine
department that's the north mayor
location
and dr chang my name is ian shay
i'm an internal medicine physician
working
now and on demand department which
consists of urgent care convenient care
and
the telemedicine service called now
clinic wow and dr tray what does your
day-to-day look like
give us a behind-the-scenes look
so i now mostly work in telemedicine
area called mountain clinic so i see
patients over the video
i listen to their conditions
and i formulate diagnosis and vendor
treatment plans to them and surprisingly
a lot of conditions can be easily
diagnosed appropriately diagnosed over
the video visits
and patients because they don't have to
travel anywhere
they can log in from their own living
room wow and of course that's a sign of
the times maria how has it been working
in healthcare
during this pandemic for you and the
rest of your team
you know it's been exciting uh
admittedly so it was a little
nerve-wracking at the beginning because
this was our very new sweat
but it was it's been great to see the
innovation that's come out of this
and the collaboration between different
specialties and departments
and that's something that dr chai and i
were just talking about so
um just everyone's overcome it and has
surpassed many expectations so i'm super
proud of my team and the team at
southwest market
absolutely and dr dr che can you just
let us know
what makes a good day for you
so in this challenging time patients are
looking for
answers and we are able to provide
answers for the most part
and for many patients and of course you
know
we don't know the answers sometimes and
we can point them in the right direction
and we can reassure them that they'll be
alive
even for the patients with test positive
and the fact that i can see the relief
in them that that gives me tremendous
gratification wow well thank you from
myself personally from the whole team
here at channel 8.
congratulations again dr che and maria
and thank you for
everything that you guys do please take
care
thank you very much thank you